thanks Tina for inviting me to speak
here I feel so honored I knew it was a
big deal but now I feel like it's an
even bigger deal and I'm kind of nervous
so bear with me I want to tell one quick
tidbit about Tina and why she's so
special in our life Tina was the
officiant at my wedding she's her side
side hustle and my husband who's sitting
right next to her was a Mayfield fellow
back when a long time ago when he was a
junior here at Stanford and so remember
this little story when I get to my last
slide so I want to start with a little
bit of context of Who I am and why I'm
up here talking to you today I as Tina
mentioned am a general partner at
forerunner ventures we are early stage
investor Lee stage investors in the most
transformative companies that are
redefining the consumer landscape today
and our mission is really to be the
partner of choice to the most ambitious
founders that are tackling big problems
looking for big solutions in our
category so that's our mission that's
what we do all day every day since
kicking off the firm in 2010 we have I
hope earned the reputation of being the
best-in-class investors in our space we
have a few metrics here that I'll share
we have 300 million dollars under
management we've got about 50 active
investments in our portfolio we have a
team a mighty but small team of eight
and the line of billion dollars it's a
billion dollars of portfolio revenue in
2017 that's all the revenue generated by
our companies which are very young so
this is pretty exciting a billion
dollars or more of secured follow-on
funding and all of their follow-on
rounds and then our first investment in
our first fund sold for a billion
dollars it was Dollar Shave Club to
Unilever in June of 2016 so that was
extremely exciting and a big milestone
for us and for our companies so a little
bit of context about our fund which i
think is kind of fun it's it's rare to
see a new venture fund come to light and
so with us each fund that we have had
and raised
has sort of achieved different
milestones the first fund we raised was
in 2012 it was just about 42 million
dollar fund and this was about
establishing our brand we were not my
partner Kirsten green actually started
the firm in 2010 with an angel fund and
she was investing just on you know sort
of one-off basis and with that created
the thesis for what forerunner
ultimately is which is investing in this
whole category but it's not easy to
start a venture fund when you haven't
had a long and illustrious career in
venture so it was a really unique time
in the market where seed investing was
becoming quite a new topic and micro VCS
was a new term that limited partners who
are our investors were increasingly
becoming open to so we got to ride that
wave and become first-time managers
launching fund one and really setting
out to be the only firm out there that
was focused on consumer early stage
investing that seemed to go well and so
a year and a half later we raised
seventy five million dollars in our
second fund and we really use this to
expand some of the the building blocks
that we had worked on in fund to
expanding our investment size and
expanding our investment ownership
percentages and really really trying to
deliver best-in-class
support to our portfolio companies I
think that people often say fun to is
sort of easy to raise because you
haven't had enough time to figure out a
fun one is working so you got to raise
that fund really fast so that they still
give you money
fun 3 though was really hard to raise
well it wasn't hard but it was a
nerve-wrecking because we hadn't had our
exits yet so Dollar Shave Club and jet
were our first two big exits when those
happened in June of 2016 we had to raise
our fund 3 and we closed it before those
were announced so everyone was asking
hey what are your numbers looking like
how are your companies doing and we had
to sort of stay quiet about it all but
our investor is still trusted us we
raised 122 million and we're using that
now investing out of that and we're
about no 10 or 12 positions into that
fund now and we also raised a side fund
that 60 million that sits on top of all
three funds and it invests further into
the companies in our portfolio that are
doing the best job so that's our fund
history
in one quick slide we can you know ask
me questions on it later but that gives
context for what we do and the business
that I'm in our portfolio companies are
what we are most proud of and hopefully
many of you will know some of these
names and be avid customers we were the
earliest investors in companies like
Warby Parker bonobos Birchbox
hotelTonight
they were really the first guard of all
of these next generation consumer
companies I know that obviously bonobo
started out of here at Stanford Business
School so it's something that maybe seem
so familiar to you but not so long ago
direct-to-consumer brands that wasn't a
term and really all of this selling
stuff online wasn't a thing and so when
we were investing in it it was still
pretty early days where we Parker were
it was a team that was in the business
school class a year behind me so very
very early days since then we've
invested in companies like glossier
which is a big beauty brand out in New
York
we've got Dollar Shave Club which I
mentioned had done very well in 2016
cotopaxi which is an outdoor gear brand
and a bunch of other names that
hopefully you know either now or we'll
know in the future so take a picture of
this one and check out all the website
so you can become customers but these
are these are really what make 4runner
special it's all of our founders and
it's the journey that we are on with
them to reimagine what's happening in
our space so that's enough about me when
I was talking to Tina about what to talk
to all of you about today we were
thinking about different topics and
obviously I talked to you about vendor
capital like it talking about investing
consumer companies whatever you want we
can take take it where it is so if you
think this is boring you could just wave
your hand and say you want to talk about
something else
but we thought that it would be
interesting to talk a little bit about
what success means particularly in the
context of the Entrepreneurship
ecosystem and I hope that I have a
little bit of insight to offer there
because we see 2,000 deals a year and
I'm able to talk to so many different
founders about their ideas and I get a
sense for what the different personality
types are and what what successful
traits sometimes look like I think VC is
often say that pattern recognition is
what makes us go to do our job and I
think that's
you know proving to be the case but for
the sake of the rest of my talk I'd love
to know a little bit more about who's in
the audience I know it's pretty mixed
between people who are stuck here in
class and have to be here and then a
bunch of people who are here for
interests so how many of you have
interest in being a VC you already have
a job a little bit how many of you want
to work at a startup company all right
ooh that's good I'm at Stanford I expect
everybody to say that and how many of
you want to be a founder ok and how many
of you wouldn't want to be all three
there we go that's really helpful I will
try to tailor the conversation through
it along the way so I think that we all
have different interests but the one
thing that probably binds us all is that
we all think I want to be successful but
what does that mean it's different to
different people and so you know people
ask me you know how did you get to where
you are and all the stuff and I'm
sitting here thinking I don't know I
just it's my job I don't really feel
like where I am is particularly
successful in a more general term it's
something that I love doing but then I
realize that for a lot of people this is
where people want to be and especially
sitting in where you are and your seats
you're trying to figure out what you
want to do when you get out of school
and there's a lot of options and it's
almost a tyranny of choice and so some
of this talk is just about how do you
parse out those decisions and figure out
if there's a framework that works for
you to determine what's best suited for
you at different times in your life so I
thought I'd start with a very simple
dist definition because that's a good
place to start basic definition of
success
so the dictionary says the
accomplishment of an aim or purpose or
the attainment of popularity or profit
interesting right that's all fine but
how do you get there and there seem to
be so many different ways so you know
how do you suss out which one's right
for you so I was thinking who is
successful who do I think is successful
and a bunch of I think familiar faces
came to mind for me I hope you guys all
know as Jeff Bezos right Sheryl Sandberg
this guy
anyone know who that is Mary Meeker
she's like kleiner perkins more famous
for her internet trends annual terribly
boring report sorry Mary story but
everyone has their own journey and I
think there are some journeys that are
actually really interesting too because
they're non-traditional this is Jack Ma
from Alibaba the story I love about this
is Jack had applied to Harvard ten times
and applied about 30 jobs won including
Kentucky Fried Chicken and didn't get
into any of them so I'm sure they're
pretty bummed out that they didn't let
him and you know this guy and then
Katrina Lake just took her company
public she's the founder and CEO of
stitch fix and the Elon Musk of course
and these photos you know I don't know
if you know their profiles but the first
slide has a bunch of common traits where
they would have gone to a grade school
they might have gone into finance they
maybe did a MBA they worked at a great
company really a sort of more
traditional path I think this slide has
people that did a lot of different
things and there are plenty of people
out there that I know you guys have even
heard come speak at this class even
who've had much more sort of
serendipitous paths and so you know I
can't speak to all these guys they're a
lot more successful than me but I can
share a little bit about my journey in
case it's helpful for you and really the
goal of my journey story is not to bore
you but to offer a little bit of a
framework so bear with me is gonna be my
journey so far so I did start at
Berkeley sorry about that you know it
was I'm gonna date myself but it was
back 1998 to 2002 2001 so it was the
dot-com number one and the startup
frenzy was crazy on campus I think that
it was still pretty consolidated towards
the engineering groups and so I just
have I didn't think that I could be part
of that I was studying business and I
didn't know anything about technology
and so it was hard to figure out if I
could participate so I was just plugging
along doing my own thing and then
somebody that was my resident assistant
in my dorm he literally checked people
in as they came in through the door he
turned out he wanted to start a company
and he had a group of seven engineers
that were banding together to work on a
mobile software kind of mobile phone
technology startup and this was when the
phone was the nokia right so I have set
that stage there was no iPhone for like
10 more years and this was a feature
phone it did all but basically call and
text but our idea was pretty neat it was
this idea of taking text and
hyperlinking important words and then
making actions out of that so if it was
you know hey Yuri meet me at the pizza
place at 3:00 the pizza place would be
hyperlinked you could map it you could
call it you could do a lot of things
that surprised we can do right now with
our iPhones so it was incredibly early
too early didn't really work out but
ultimately it was the most amazing
experience because it was the first time
I got a taste of that startup energy
I knew though even while I was doing it
that I didn't feel like it was going to
be something that I would be able to
really sink my teeth into and it was
because it wasn't my idea and it wasn't
something I was uniquely qualified to do
it was something that I was
opportunistically offered an opportunity
to participate in and so that's why I
took it and I learned from it and I
think that was great but ultimately I
thought about what else I could do and I
ended up going a more traditional path
and getting an internship at Bain where
I think you guys all know is a
consulting firm and ended up having the
best summer of my life doing that
internship and I think that that was a
bit surprising to me because you think
you're going to this big company and and
you know kind of seen boring but what
you really get is a lot of wonderful
people that are all super smart and
really excited about new things and you
get to collaborate together in this team
environment for a very consolidated
period of time and so from there I
literally look back at all of the people
that I work with and collaborate with
now and so many of them are from Bain
and from that time in my life and so
it's just such a it's a special treat to
be able to do that thinking back you
know 12 15 years later that people that
I had gone to parties with and you know
gone on vacations with are really people
that I do business with every day today
you know at the time that I was at being
I was still noodling on my own idea I
always had sort of that entrepreneurial
bug but I just didn't I don't feel like
I had enough skills yet and so I thought
okay well if I maybe go into investing
I'll learn
raise money for my company idea in the
future and maybe learn how to build a
business and ultimately be more
successful and so I sought out retail
and consumer specific fund and this was
a firm that's out in Boston now and it
was started by the former CEOs of Neiman
Marcus group and I think that what I'd
credit myself with is not necessarily
knowing what I ever wanted to do with my
life but just knowing that I had
interest in consumer retail and so from
a very early stage I started setting
that as sort of a thing a drumbeat in
each of the decisions that I made and so
I spent a lot of time there I probably
worked the hardest I'd ever worked in my
entire life even to date in these two
years 100 hour weeks steep learning
curve I didn't know how to do anything
but I just got so many hard skills that
I use every day today and you know part
of the reason I haven't worked that hard
is because honestly when you work that
hard like everything else feels easy you
just know how to cope with different
challenges in your life and I think that
those moments are always really
important to get in your life
particularly early in your career but
all that set me up for a really neat
opportunity and it was actually my what
is that second startup opportunity which
sounded super sexy it was moved to
London work at an incubator for fashion
designers investing in fashion designers
I mean if that doesn't sound cool I
don't know what does so I got really
excited I told my boss over at Casa de
I'm gonna quit I'm gonna move to London
I'm gonna do this I need just looked I
mean he's like you know what you have a
great job here it's stable you know your
promotion why would you leave all of
that I just thought I'm 26 years old I
just want to try something different I
wanna I want to get out there and learn
and see what's out there
and I knew that the risk was high I
didn't know the team I didn't know the
founder but I really thought that this
would stretch me and give me an
opportunity to get out of my comfort
zone so I took it I think a hot three
months later it imploded I mean it was
it was not gonna work out the cofounders
had a falling out one of them had the
money one of them had the idea the money
left and so here I was no job in London
one of the most expensive cities in the
world and I didn't know what to do
so what do you do when you don't know
what to do you fly to school so I lied
to school thank God I got in I got into
Wharton I was very happy
about that and I spent the next six
months just hanging out in London doing
some more consulting more thinking about
my idea but I was like okay I've got my
network from Bain I've got my skills
from kasnia I've moved to London I can
deal with challenges I'm ready to start
a company like if I'm not ready now I
mean I'm just talking and I'm never
gonna do it so I was like I'm gonna go
to school and I'm gonna start this
company so that's what I did I spent my
entire time in Business School working
on my own idea it was not particularly
novel it's a handbag company
direct-to-consumer before that was a
term I mean I really was too early
because I think if it was five years
later I would have been much cooler but
ultimately I spent my entire time
getting on my internship during my two
years was there and I had a blast but it
was it was lonely I was by myself I
don't know if you've gathered but I am
not a designer but I was designing my
own bags bags but I was trying and I was
having a really good time and I was all
set to graduate and move to New York and
start my company and finally I was going
to be the person that I wanted to be
this amazing founder and have my own
thing and then everything oh that was it
called me even sorry and then everything
grinded to a screeching halt and about a
month after I graduated from Wharton I
got a call from my mom on a Sunday
afternoon saying that I needed to come
home because my dad might not make it
and I said make it to what and she said
oh well he had a heart attack so he
might not make it you should get home
and I thought wow dad's not even sick I
think I talked to him three days ago and
he played golf and it was the first time
that I just my whole world was shattered
and I didn't have any idea what I was
going to do so I went home about it huh
so I went home and I my dad did pass
away and I realized that all the things
that I've been working on for so long
was all about me and all about my job
and all about all of us like being a
founder and it all just didn't matter
anymore
everything seems so trite and so I spent
the next six months hanging out with my
mom we have a we had a small cafe and
she obviously couldn't run it anymore so
we need to wind it down
so I spent a lot of time with her just
talking and making sandwiches she would
love telling everybody that I was great
I had graduated from Wharton really
awkward when you're selling a three
dollar sandwich and someone's telling
you about like they graduated from
Wharton and she says successful and
whatever and they're looking at me going
okay why are you flipping my sandwich um
so it was definitely a humbling time but
but it was a special time for my family
and for me and for growing and realizing
what was important and so that all went
fine the story is not about being sad
but the story is about priorities and it
is about how life changes and it abscent
flows and obviously zigs and zags
throughout your opportunities in life
and so after that I had like zero risk
appetite but I still needed jobs I need
to pay for stuff so I decided I was
going to go back to bein and I was gonna
Reese
sort of a core for what was going on in
my life and I needed to focus on
something that I was good at focus on
something I could do and I could move
forward I'm gonna end up being an
incredible decision because I ended up
reinventing ort of reinvigorating my
network I'd been gone from the Bay Area
for five or six years even seven years
and so I'd spent the entire time that
was back at Bane back in commerce
consulting for eBay Nordstrom on their
e-commerce strategy and it really
started to come together where there was
a moment that so much was happening in
the industry that being able to see it
from that big company perspective was
really special and it was really only
then that I started feeling like okay
life is starting to settle down I'm
starting to get my entrepreneurial bug
back I don't necessarily want to be a
consultant my whole life and I have to
make that decision because if I take
this promotion I got to stay so I
thought about what else I wanted to do
and I thought you know I think it's more
important for me to be doing something
entrepreneurial and having something
that is super stable that's just my
that's my drumbeat and so I started
looking for new jobs I started think
about new eiji ideas I had a couple of
offers for startup companies but you
know at the time honestly I couldn't
take a $50,000 salary it was just too
much of a pay cut it was the realities
of life setting in and then I thought
okay well I don't have my own idea and
much less I don't have my own team so I
can't start my own thing
so you know maybe I'll work at Google or
Facebook and just get back in the game
be with entrepreneurial people people
who are doing different things and a
place where you yourself can start to
come out and shine and so I started
thinking in that manner and just about
then I actually met Kirsten who's my
partner at forerunner and she was you
know we met through a business school
classmate of mine who was on the board
of a company with her and she was in the
process of wanting to raise a fun but
she had no team and she really wanted a
partner and so we met over coffee and
obviously things worked out because I've
been with her for six and a half years
longer than my husband and and things
truly came all together and so a lot of
people won't think of 4runner as a
startup but I would say it absolutely is
and has been for the last six or seven
years we're kind of a series B company I
would say we sort of product market fit
we've got some traction but we haven't
necessarily returned a bunch of money
yet so you know there's still room to go
but we're definitely in a mode where
we're really proud of what we've done
and excited for the future so that is me
enough about me actually all of this is
hopefully gonna come together so that
you can use it as a framework for
yourself
and so in in consulting jargon answer
first is something that you have to use
in all presentations it's because they
assume that nobody's listening and so I
have to tell you what I'm going to tell
you and what the takeaways are before I
tell you the takeaways I'm gonna have to
repeat the takeaways later so that's
what I'm gonna do here these are my
takeaways there's gonna be a quiz later
path to success are nonlinear I don't
know if you gathered from my chart but
it kept on booing back and forth from
above the line to below the line it
meant that I always felt like I was
entrepreneurial but I wasn't able to be
entrepreneurial every single moment of
my career and that depended on where I
was in my life and what opportunities
came by my way and so when you think
about gosh I'm gonna graduate or I'm in
school I really really want to be
successful like here's somebody I really
respect I'm gonna copy her path it's
just never gonna work because you're you
and I'm me and
you're special in other ways and you
need to figure out what's going to work
for you and what opportunities come and
so all you need to do though is to
figure out what things drive you and
what you are uniquely qualified to go
and do and you might not know what that
is today but you will certainly grow to
learn that over time with each
experience there are a lot of ways to
participate in the entrepreneurial
ecosystem I think almost everybody
raised their hand when it came to
wanting to work at a startup company or
wanting to be a founder but there's more
ways to participate in the ecosystem
than just that and those might be
experiences you want now but when will
you do them are you gonna do them when
you're 22 when you're 32 and you're 42
or 80 to it it doesn't matter right you
can have all of those opportunities for
you every role has its own benefits and
drawbacks and I'm actually going to
spend a bunch of slides going into each
role and some of the nuances of them
that I can share with you so that you
can hopefully take that away and the
most important thing is that your first
job is definitely not your last job I
think if you ask anyone in the room that
isn't necessarily in college they'll
probably have six seven eight nine jobs
and all of them come together to weave a
really fascinating story for where the
person comes from and where they're
going so I'm gonna go back to this later
but of all the roles that we've talked
about most of them I've actually done
and I think that there are a lot out
there that you're probably noodling on I
think that the biggest question in in
your minds is probably why is number one
a big company that doesn't seem
particularly entrepreneurial but I would
argue that it absolutely is it is a
place where you can gain a lot of skills
and most importantly in a really large
network so I'm gonna go through each of
these separately so take your little
pictures but no presentation is complete
without a two-by-two matrix so I'm gonna
give you it do by doing matrix there are
so many ways that you can evaluate your
own opportunity set and I picked two
vectors here financial flexibility and
risk appetite the reason I pick those
two is because of the hundreds of people
I talk to every year who come to me and
say I want to start a company
I want to be working at a start-up after
about two minutes it's obvious that
they're never gonna do it and it's
because the realities of life pop in and
you know when I asked them okay well are
you okay with foregoing salary for two
years and I look at me horrified they're
like well no how will I pay for my bills
and I'm like well that's a good question
I don't know they feel often like you
can do something on the side so I'm
gonna keep my job at Google but I'm
gonna do this thing on the side and then
when it goes really big then I'll quit
my job and then I'll switch over so that
is a genius idea that I've tried to
really doesn't work like how can you
have this amazing breakout idea if you
have one foot out and one foot in you
don't have enough time or energy I mean
it takes so much time to make it
successful even if someone's working 100
hours a week on their ideas most of the
time it's not successful how is it gonna
be if it's only 20 hours a week and so I
think that the financial flexibility is
the sort of real like rubber meets the
road you need to ask yourself if now is
the time for you to really be
entrepreneurial I mean the risk appetite
is an interesting one because there's
just the risk appetite of you know
quitting your job and not knowing what
you're gonna go do figuring out that
99.9% of all startups are gonna fail
so if you're gonna join one or start one
yourself are you okay with failure those
are sort of the natural risk appetite
things that come to mind but then
there's also just the daily risk
appetite do you feel anxious when you go
to work and you have no idea what you're
supposed to do today do you feel nervous
if you don't know what success looks
like and you don't know if you can hit
the mark and get an A
because there's no grades in
entrepreneurship you have no idea what
you're doing you have to create your own
goals and milestones and you still even
if you meet meet the milestones the
milestones are always moving and so I
think that that's where a lot of people
start to get really fatigued from being
in the entrepreneurial entrepreneurial
ecosystem where they just feel like gosh
I just want to go somewhere where I know
what it looks like to be a rock star and
then I can go do that
and it feels better to be able to
accomplish that and so it's not a
surprise how these all fit onto the map
you know low low is that if you work at
a big company you get a nice big
salary you know where you're going you
know what success looks like you have a
management team and then all the way up
to founder is where you have high risk
potentially high reward but ultimately
extremely high need to have flexibility
financially
I think everyone only thinks about
founders as being like the breakout
success billionaires not the case most
people I would say make less than
$80,000 of all the founders in my
portfolio founders are the first people
that forgo their salary when the cash
runs then they're the last people to get
a raise I mean it really is something
that is all-encompassing and it's really
hard on you and your family most
importantly because many times it
doesn't work out so you've done five
years of your life dedicating to this
company that doesn't work out what is
that gonna feel like to you and is that
okay so that's how I mapped it here the
next few slides I thought it would be
helpful to go into each role get some of
what I felt when I was in your shoes was
how do I know if I'm gonna like it like
how do I know if working at a big
company is for me or working at a
startup is for me
so each one I don't know if it's helpful
everyone notices but each one of these
slides goes through what characteristics
might make you more suited for this job
at this time in your life and I want to
tell you that specifically relative to
time because it doesn't mean that you
can't do something else later and and
then what are the key benefits and
drawbacks
so for working in a big company I think
people all realize I mean all of these
roles you have to be smart and tenacious
and hardworking and determined like
let's just assume that all of that is
the case I I think that you're all at
Stanford so it's probably even a step
above but I'll assume but here it's
actually this idea of being eager to be
taught it's not eager to learn it's that
you thrive when someone else is teaching
you how to do things and you love
feeling like that mentorship and
training is stabilizing in your life
this is a place that you're gonna get it
when you go to Google you have I don't
know how many different teams and
mentors and you know places that you can
get advice that is not the case when
you're at a startup
everyone's so busy
they don't they don't even know they
don't care what your problem is because
they got problems of their own
so eager to be taught team-oriented
thrives with instructure and also I see
that being competitive is something that
is a trait that fits low with being in a
big company that seems a little bit
weird to say but it's because you can't
be competitive if there's no one else
doing your job so if you're really
competitive you really need a class of
people doing your job you need a banking
class you need an associate class
because then you know that you're better
than that guy who's doing your job and
you're just doing it better and that
makes you really happy and so this is a
good place to go do that if you work as
a founder or startup company like
there's no one else you can't compete
they're like you're all in the same boat
together so I think that kind of draws
out the biggest difference for me in
this and this big company arena the key
benefit obviously is the credibility
stemming from the brand that you have I
would say in the beginning of your
career being able to stamp the resume
with something like Stanford or
something like Facebook or Microsoft is
amazing you can also go and do that
startup but understand that if that
startup fails then the three years that
you are working at it kind of don't they
don't resonate with anybody so that's
not giving you the credibility that
something else might
and the biggest drawbacks are there are
a handful but I think the biggest one
for somebody that might be in your chair
is that the hierarchy limits outlier
opportunities so when you're at a
startup company you can be 25 years old
and all of a sudden you can be the VP of
Marketing that is not gonna happen at
Microsoft and I think that you know
there are Goods and Bad's to that but
regardless if you feel like you need to
have more autonomy and more room to grow
and you want to have that ambiguity then
this is definitely not going to be a
place to do it
and I think then FOMO is the worst
feeling ever
when you work in a big company and I
felt that a lot at Bain where I I
distinctly remember telling my family
and my friends I feel like I'm living in
the Jetsons but I'm working for the
Flintstones like you're saying Jets
going around in autonomous vehicles
literally and I'm helping a company that
is just super archaic and some people
love that I did not which is
why I knew in my heart that I could
never stay there and then I needed to do
something anything where people were
thinking about tomorrow gross so this is
kind of series B and onward the question
is being is a very different what did
you choose it
I wish i oh so the question is vein is a
different big company than maybe some
other big companies out there I think
specifically given how entrepreneurial a
lot of the people have ended up being
outside of Bain so the question that Tom
asked was why did I choose it I don't
have a good answer they were I was late
to the internship recruiting you know
Slough that was the last entrant
internship I couldn't apply for and I
got it and I went there that's the real
answer it is lucky I in retrospect I'm
so grateful that this is the place I
landed because when you think about all
the different companies you can work at
there is an entrepreneurial culture no
matter what if you're big or small and
there are actually small teams that have
a non entrepreneurial culture as well so
it is about understanding the nuances of
the actual opportunity and not just
saying oh it's big company like I don't
like it or with a small company I'm
gonna work there cuz it's a start-up
because the the environment around you
really shapes that but Bain is
absolutely one of them more entren you
know so are all the tech companies I
mean if you work at Facebook you can't
not say that that's entrepreneurial it's
it's a big company but it's still that's
why I say that big company is still a
part of the ecosystem right and it's a
wonderful place in the ecosystem how are
you doing on time okay keep going
okay I've got a few of these right so on
growth stage this is just so you know
growth is kind of series B Series C a
little bit later so you know even an
uber and airbnb these are really good
for people when you know what you're
good at you kind of are a domain expert
you have an ability to manage team
now you finally are starting to get big
enough to have a team and you are okay
with just constantly evolving
responsibilities everything is changing
so fast it's called growth stage for
reason and the sort of axis is straight
up and Assam total and so you know you
need to be really really really good at
setting your own goals and milestones to
be able to get forward and move forward
and you can't be waiting for someone
else to tell you what to do or that you
get a good job like that is not a good
place for you that needs to be at the
big company I think that the key
drawbacks honestly are that the pace of
change is so fast and furious that a lot
of people get stomped on in the process
you don't get enough time to learn what
you're doing as soon as you figure out
what you're doing tomorrow your job is
different and it's really hard to then
feel like everything you're spending all
your time doing doesn't matter because
tomorrow looks different so you need to
be okay with that and if you're not is
not a good place for you and by the way
don't ever expect management to be
strong at a growth stage company because
the person that's managing you today
yesterday was a customer service
associate like it's just it's crazy how
fast it goes but to the point of having
outlier opportunities if you are that
type of person that can just hit an
opportunity you know hit the ground
running and just take it along as fast
as you can go and this is a place that
you'll go fast I said the right timing
here is when you know what you're good
at because some people come to me and
they say oh you know I don't know what I
want to do maybe marketing maybe supply
chain maybe engineering I'm like what
are you doing go back to school you know
if you know what you're good at it's
much easier at these jobs because you
can get in have a skill set that you're
applying and again be successful push
the ball forward early stage this is
where I am this is where we see most of
our companies it's probably less than 20
people on the team there's not
necessarily a product market fit here
it's really great if you're a generalist
if you're enthusiastic about the product
and the company and you're comfortable
with extreme ambiguity again you do not
know what you're doing day in and day
out you have a general sense of what the
goals are but things are changing really
and so that this needs to be something
you're okay with super skill here is
being a jack-of-all-trades because you
actually can be the operations person
and the customer service person and the
marketing person because there's only
five people on your team the hard part
is over time you have people join the
team that take over parts of those
responsibilities and so you might feel a
little bit frustrated that everyone's
like changing the rules of the game and
now you don't know what your job is and
so there's there some drawbacks or
asking questions if you have deeper
questions the drawbacks are you know the
moving targets the lack of formal
training I would say the small network
is really important when people don't
think about so when I went to Bane
there's you know 20 people in my own
class 300 people in the office thousands
of people worldwide I know a lot of
people within my network now if you join
a class of five in a startup company
there's four other people that know you
so that's what you have is your network
and I think that it is very different if
it's the right four people you're okay
but if it's not the right four people
and you don't like each other it's not
it's not okay it's really hard and so I
said the right timing here is when
you're passionate about the idea and the
team because you need that passion to
feel you forward okay so founding team
this is different than being a founder
I'm gonna end with the founder slide but
the founding team is that you need
complementary skills you may not
necessarily have the idea but maybe
you're really good at technology at
coding so you can be the CTO maybe
you're really good at marketing so you
could be the CMO or the marketing person
but in this founding team it's like less
than five so you're one of the first few
people hired or maybe your co-founders
together but the most important thing is
that you have a lane and something that
you're good at as well as being
generalists cuz you got to do more
things but like you have one thing that
you're good at and people can look at
you and say okay Yuri does this like
that makes sense the opportunity though
is is difficult because I mean I would
say the key benefit is you know learning
learning how to be a founder without
necessarily having to be the founder so
if you have aspirations this is what I
did at the first startup is I was
learning all of these nuances of
starting a company but it wasn't really
like my official first company of my own
so the failure quote-unquote not
necessarily mine but at this
time you learn a lot so that's a lot of
the benefit but I think that's exactly
what the drawback is it's not your thing
so it's hard to be up all night long
killing yourself trying to do this many
times I'll be really honest the equity
split is not even so the founder will
have 50 plus percent and the founding
team will have ten or less so that's a
big difference and somebody very wise
sitting right there Rosa told me that
the risk of founding a company and being
on the founding team are very similar
and so if you're gonna do it you might
as well start your own thing because at
least you're gonna learn trial by fire
you know really kind of put your put
your you know thoughts to the test but I
do think that for many people this is
more comforting to have all the fun of
starting a company and have the
collaboration of starting a company but
not necessarily have to do it all by
yourself so more than half the room
wants to be a founder I would say the
characteristics of a great founder more
often than not are that you're an
inventor that you're often thinking
about new things that you're a
self-starter that you're passionate and
that you're a problem solver those are
sort of common across everything at
four-runner people always ask us what
makes a great founder and we've
consolidated it to three adjectives
magnetic disciplined and visionary the
reason is your job as a founder is to
sell all day long you're selling to your
investors you're selling to your family
members who are asking you why you don't
have a real job you're selling to your
team who wants to quit because no one's
getting paid and they don't know what
they're doing and you're like no don't
leave this is gonna be a big thing
you're selling to every single person
all day long and so if you are not
magnetic and people aren't naturally
drawn to you in some way it is really
hard to do this non-stop so the best
founders in our portfolio are ones where
people will drop their jobs and join no
salary no anything and they just want to
be with the founder doing this thing the
discipline side is a hope a little bit
obvious but you've got like five dollars
in your bank account and you have a lot
of things you have to accomplish so are
you the type of person that's going to
know exactly what
needs to be done to move the needle
forward nothing more nothing less you
know what it takes minimum viable
product to show what you're trying to do
and that is something that we see in our
best founders visionary is that I am NOT
in the business of funding good
companies I'm in the business and I get
paid to find extraordinary outlier
companies venture capital is only
successful on outliers and so if you're
not visionary if you're thinking I'm
gonna build this great company and I
think that it's gonna be 50 million
dollars in five years and we're gonna
make five million dollars of cash flow
that's amazing and that's a lot of money
in your pocket but that does not make me
successful that does not make our
endowments and our you know LPS
successful who've invested in forerunner
and so if visionary isn't a word you
would use to describe yourself or your
future goals maybe this isn't something
that you want to do the super skill
going along with magnetic is that this
job is all about hiring 100% hiring if
you can hire the team to win you don't
need to be the smartest person in the
room you don't need to be the best
person you need to be the people to you
need to be the person to know who to
bring onto your team and to get them
there and empower them to do their job
if you're good at that you'll be a
successful founder and the benefit there
is a hundred percent ownership it is
yours it's your baby no matter how ugly
it is it's your baby
and it's fun you know I do think it's a
lot of fun to have that type of
ownership but the key drawbacks and I
would say people don't think about this
is it's incredibly lonely there's no one
else that you can turn to because it's
all on you you have your partners and
you can talk to your friends but
ultimately when you can't make payroll
that's on your shoulders and that is a
heavy burden for anybody so the
loneliness is real the instability
obviously is it is what it it is what it
is and the high beta is I think what a
lot of people get excited by it's just
this huge huge outcome potential but
with that is just a huge zero and I
think after that it's hard to rally the
right timing here I would say is when
you're ready I mean that's kind of
stupid but it's true you'll know in your
heart if you're ready to start this I
knew that I wasn't ready until I was
and then when the thing happened with my
family I wasn't ready anymore and so you
have to know where your risk appetite
and your financial flexibility makes
sort of meets in the middle and crosses
over with that founder founder bucket it
obviously helps if you have an idea and
some experience in the space but you
don't need it I mean I think there's a
lot of founders that get out there and
just want to do something and they're
hungry and trying stuff test and iterate
and so you can still be successful doing
that and the mentor investor I mean it's
a fun job I would say you know
big-picture thinking my super skill is
psychology I didn't realize that was
going to come in half you know handy but
it's all about empowering founders and
understanding how to motivate people so
these are things that I think a lot of
people wouldn't imagine thinking about
venture as a finance job but this is you
know what's come out anyways I'm gonna
wrap up for the next couple slides here
so what's the right path for you we've
asked a lot of questions kind of you
know rhetorically here but what are your
core personality traits what's your risk
appetite
what's your financial flexibility you
know what motivates you because when you
start asking yourself these questions
they're different than how am I supposed
to be successful what's the best job to
get you know what's gonna sound the best
on my resume like those are not the
right questions to ask yourself that's
not gonna get you there but these ones
are gonna help you and hopefully some of
the stuff in these slides are gonna help
you as well so we do it key takeaways
this is the quiz path to success
nonlinear there are a lot of ways to
participate in entrepreneurship do not
think that starting your own company has
to be the only way and certainly it
doesn't have to be the only way today
you can do it any other time in your
life and there are opportunities all
along the way every role has its own
benefits and drawbacks I don't think
that anyone's grass is greener it is not
it's just as hard but in different ways
and your first job is not your last job
so please don't stress out too much
about it just have fun and make sure
that you're learning and make sure that
you're doing something that brings out
the best in you so I'll do one final
thought actually there's two but secret
to success no secret to success : Powell
come on it's not my idea it's the result
of preparation hard work and learning
from failure
I think that people forget that failure
is the only thing that really helps push
you to the edges and if you haven't
failed you probably haven't pushed
yourself hard enough so try stuff this
is college do everything try all the
jobs you can literally have all kinds of
internships and so that's the best
benefit that you get from being in
school where you are and not that Colin
Powell needs the PostScript but I wanted
to end with I talked a lot about this
but remember I started the conversation
by saying I'm here because I met Tina
who knew my husband a long long time ago
and I think what I've learned in my
career in this career is that my network
has been the thing that makes me as
successful as I am at my job
it's people that I'm friends with for
you know all the way through since high
school it's people that I've worked with
that beign all throughout my life people
that I met when I was traveling I would
say be nice to everybody because you
never know who's gonna be on this side
of the table and you need to pitch me
and if you actually had somebody who was
not very nice to me pitch me and I
thought it was really funny I did not
find that person but it is it is you can
always find opportunity in people so try
to build your network my lovely mother
used to always say birds of a feather
together flocking
she's really eloquent but birds of a
feather flock together so you guys are
all with amazing people here at Stanford
your alumni tap your network build your
network and please have fun and enjoy so
I'm opening up for questions
hi my name is Noah
CEO and co-founder of a start-up that's
building learning platforms for emerging
market but the question is enough to
learn what your perspective is as the VC
on the emerging amount of finances that
are going into impact focused
investments and if you see that in your
job raising your funds or just where you
think that's going overall well I mean I
think it's um it's really important just
for those yes so Noah asked what we're
seeing in terms of impact investing and
and sort of my general thoughts on the
trends in that space I'll be honest
there are some parts of my job that I
just love and I'm so passionate about we
don't get to do impact investing because
that's not what we signed up for and
that's not what our LPS signed up for so
we have a charter where each LP invest
in a fund because they want you to
return a certain level of beta like risk
profile impact investing is something
that's very different and I'm so excited
that more people are are focused on it
what's hard is venture is about making
money and there's a lot of ways to make
money and you can do it with impact but
I find that if you can invest in
companies that have sound business
models that have goals and mission
statements that are really resonating
with their customers they will in fact
have that impact and so we see that a
lot of our companies will donate X
percent of their revenues to different
causes or they'll donate products and
that's another way of impact or social
impact that they're able to do but in
terms of general impact investing we're
seeing more firms created but it's kind
of a different class of investors this
is cool I mean if somebody is investing
myself in the consumer space dissimilar
to foreigners
we shouldn't eat rats done with what you
must be doing soil first let's see very
excited in the space I feel on the many
reasons why it's so exciting right now
from a custom experience brand
experience and nearly a year to stay in
the likes of hiring horrible
requirements and after your from your
affected why do you think on some of the
challenges that they could face
especially in the Amazon there and what
you really see a perfect Christians
Porto sufficiently she mentioned that
having Amazon contracted people wound
and a hard and dry but after yoga
perspex on the transit digital natives
will Pollard yeah because Katie going
forward the everyone's getting trade
like we have awoken can change the shape
of the people in color even like Heidi's
you've done a shame it the populace
getting charged so I'm not really
worried about some done so the question
was around direct to consumer brands
digitally native brands and what the
chat they're growing really rapidly now
there's a lot of brands out there so
what are the challenges are gonna face
specifically in the market may be
relative to Amazon and you think that's
a great question I think wouldn't we
think about digitally native brands it's
just the fact that for generations past
there's always been an influx of new
brands it's just that today they're
digitally native because there's no
other way to start a company why
wouldn't you start it online you get to
know your customers so much sooner and
better I think that the threat of Amazon
is real I mean they're obviously an
extremely formidable competitor but they
don't create they do try to create
brands but they don't have the
relationship that our brands have with
the customer so the reason why we invest
in the brands is that they stay out of
Amazon's fray at least to enable growth
you know away and Warby Parker and
Dollar Shave Club are able to get to the
multi hundreds of millions because
they're doing something of their own and
they own their whole supply chain I
think the trick will be can they scale
beyond just that can they create a
lifestyle brand that's going to be
sustainable can they grow with their
millennial customer who's changing
preferences are honestly so difficult to
pinpoint I mean so how do you invest
from an investment standpoint not in a
product not even in a brand but in a
whole sort of way of life in a lifestyle
in an ecosystem where the team has a
pulse on who the customer is and is able
to change along the way and we think
that that's the opportunity because
there are trillions of dollars being
spent on clothes shoes accessories
anything in and around your home and
your life all the brands that there were
yesterday
they need to fight to stay relevant with
you tomorrow and so in that fight the
new brands are coming to life and we
believe that you all as customers are
willing to give them a try presumably
because they check all the boxes on the
table there what characteristics are
Nike and what not but of all those
things still that's all make it you've
got a high potential but didn't
mayonnaise what were some of the reasons
so the question is we see a lot of deals
and so if it's to the point where we've
invested in the deal it's made it down a
funnel pretty tight and so why are those
even still many of those are not
successful and I would say a lot of it
is execution a lot of it is the founder
that they weren't maybe as magnetic and
visionary and disciplined as we had
expected them to be it's surprising but
it's usually the founder it's usually
the founder and so there are many times
where even we will make the thought of
there's this amazing idea and we really
want to do something in this space and
like this team seems like they've got it
all together they just look perfect on
paper and you know in the back of your
mind you feel like I'm a little bit
worried about this one thing but we're
just gonna do it because it's it's just
the perfect deal they don't work out
they don't work out when you feel like
you've got the founder that you would
back thicker thin no matter their
starting this company or another company
those are the ones that are winning
right now in our portfolio and I think
that's what we need to stay honest to it
is very hard to do that though because
you see all kinds of things all kinds of
noise and you want to believe you want
to drink your own kool-aid right and and
there are a lot of good storytellers out
there and so you have to pinpoint what
do you think the founder of this company
needs to be great at to be able to make
this company successful it's different
than this other
company so we often say you know why are
you uniquely qualified to be the company
founder of this idea and if they have no
real reason to start this one versus
another one probably not so the question
is you know let's let's take the founder
issue and the co-founders issue aside
because that's actually the lion share
of why why a lot of companies fail I
would say that the other reason is lack
of focus because the what happens is you
get somebody or a team that's actually
really good and they get the product to
market they get the angel funding or the
first round of funding and they start
going and are super excited and so they
get all this momentum and they get a big
series a ton and then what happens they
hire 40 people they expand their office
they expand to LA and New York and
Dallas and all of a sudden it's just a
mess and so I think that that lack of
discipline it still goes back to the
founder but I think it's just it's
focused and like execution-wise
that people can't figure out what is it
that you have to prove to be able to
make that next step in the back the
questions what's my method of keeping in
touch with my network I think it's a
really good question because I can't say
that I had a like a process for it I
think that I got really lucky because I
like people and I like keeping in touch
my but I liked keeping in touch with my
friends and it's really frustrating when
you know someone's trying to network
with you right like they're checking in
there you know it just seems like they
want something from you
and I think that networking at its best
is when you know that you have to give
to be able to receive and all throughout
my life I've been giving a lot to a lot
of people and now that's coming back
around where it's not necessarily
helping me but it's it's helping people
around me that that might benefit from
that so I would say if you want to
network be really good at you know
figuring out how you can help others so
that people come to you right what a
wonderful way to end thank you so much
thank you so much dad
[Applause]
you